okay so we have about 20 people online
they were just finishing up oh okay well
we'll wait another minute or so then
okay
when they're here we'll start we're just
waiting for a few more
people to come
so we have a
decent sized audience wow okay
hey
okay and we now have 23 people online
are we ready to begin
great well um i want to welcome everyone
to our
thursday
d mice research conference um we have
about uh about eight or nine people in
here
and um
23 or so online so a nice uh
turnout and we have a an international
visitor today
um who i had the opportunity to talk
with a little uh earlier and who um is a
um
brought here by his former mentor adeeb
who most of you know is one of our
faculty
um
and um
so i
um as i always do when people come to
visit i say you got to give a talk and
so he's going to give a talk so it gives
me great pleasure to introduce dr abu
sayed mohammed latiful hak
who is a professor in the department of
computer science and engineering in at
the bangladesh university of engineering
and technology um and um he
has sounds like he's had many students
in his career including adebe um and
he is he's going to talk to us today
um about
an
an effort in bangladesh to
build a national health um data
warehouse i'll let him explain the
details he told me a little bit about it
when we met um
just um by history he uh obtained a phd
in from the department of computer and
information science at the university of
strathclyde which is in glasgow in the
uk
in 2003 and his research areas include
health informatics data warehouse and
mining data warehousing and mining big
data management and analysis and
e-learning
he served as chair of the acm
association for computing machinery uh
in at the bangladesh university of
engineering technology in 2015 and 2016.
he's a fellow of the bangladesh computer
society and a fellow of the institution
of engineers in bangladesh he currently
leads the
systems research and development
laboratory
which is developed to focus applied
research in the area of health data
analytics and e-learning a topic of
great interest to us here in d mice
and so um
he's he's had a number of collaborations
in industry and with other
um
universities including the university of
marquette
in wisconsin
and um other places so i uh i will uh i
won't take up all this time i'll let him
um uh give his talk here as as we've
been doing since we've kind of come back
from the pandemic is um
he will he's presenting here those who
are out on webex are seeing the slides
and uh uh maybe a little bit of video
once he's done talking we'll hopefully
have some time for uh question and
answer
and um this uh owl unit these all units
that we've been using seem to be working
pretty well
for that purpose and and we'll also um
uh make sure we capture questions that
come in over webex so um go ahead dr hot
thanks a lot to demise and remy's chair
for inviting me for giving the
opportunity to present my research work
in this department in this
honor seminar
so today i am now going to
present the big data in health the
perspective of developing countries like
bangladesh
so this is my content
national clinical data warehouse the
multi-dimensional research opportunities
in health and informatics
really it is a massive
uh data
warehouse there are lots of
opportunities for research so i'll talk
firstly about the record linkage problem
and how we solve the recordings problems
in bangladesh and develop a rapper-based
data
anonymization technique and
needs a lot of data pre-processing and
standardization
of our data and integration of
environmental factors with the data to
have
through research on infectious disease
and finally i'll talk something about
the research upon the opportunity
opportunities and possible research
collaborations and second
this i as i have
on the chair has mentioned that there
are two area of my research one is
data warehouse another is e-learning so
i have developed a virtual international
system that can be used for
uh learning health data analytics i have
i already used in
my department so these are the content
of my
uh lecture today so this is my lab uh
where i i lead this level ecosystems
research and development lab department
of csu but this is the address of the
lab
so national clinical data warehouse
actually i started the work in 2015
having a phd student uh identifying the
problems of national clinical data has
like the developing countries
so we have lots of problems to integrate
the data in a big data repository so
that is why our first i worked on
on this
efficient techniques for privacy
preserved incremental record linkage of
noisy health data so this is the
this work is the basis of my national
clinical data warehouse that i'm going
to develop
after that
we uh based on this work we started to
work in the collaboration collaborative
research uh then we have the uh outcome
of the research as a privacy preserving
national clinical data warehouse it's a
model of privacy pleasurable national
clinical data house architecture
analysis and it has been published in
lcbr smart health journal and actually
this
it was presented in the conference chase
conference in washington
so i'll talk about that these are some
other publications in general big data
and you know speech technology
mainly these publications are the basis
of my national clinical data warehouse
and for administrative purpose because
if you want to do a research research on
such a
big thing so i must have some kind of
permission from the
government and clearance in bangladesh
bangladesh
medical research council bmrc that
authority to uh allow the research on
the medical data so
i
got permission from the
magnus media research council on 21st
march 2022 to integrate anonymous
clinical data from 220 hospitals
and also from the government the the
the legal and other things is
controlled by the director general of
health services so
after that we got the permission from
the director of the health services for
this intuition and they uh communicate
to the hospital so that they provide us
data now we are under the process of
signing in mou and dghs and we're so so
we can continue to develop this national
data warehouse for multiple purpose
research
so this is my research title that was
done by my phd student
here we see that record linkage how the
record linkage arises
health data from hospitals diagnosis
labs research centers bangladesh they're
scattered and hundreds and thousands of
sources are
generating health records and they are
widely distributed and there are so many
noise and so many different things
impression in working going to different
hospitals different data
so this is a huge problem
so that requires a record linkage and
at the same time it require the
privacy preservation because health
record we cannot uh
do use the health records without the
maintaining the privacy preservation so
these two issues we have we solved in
this research and we developed and uh
the privacy preserver
uh approach uh and uh framework to do
this
record linkage purpose just so that we
can
use data mining or you can any kind of
machine learning all up using this data
so what is record linkage the process of
linking records from different important
systems that represent same entity here
is an example see abdul qatar so once he
has gone to the hospital and he has
given this
information because usually this
information was tied by the office of
his attendance so they type differently
and then he has gone to for fever and
another hospital another time he has
gone this name his same patient name is
written differently and then uh
different edges uh address maybe partial
correct or not in this voicing
for different uh diagnosis so now
uh
now the question is are they the same
patient because in bangladesh there is
no patient id a national patient id or
say unique id for for the patient
records
so this is the research how can we
make sure that either these
three records are for the same patient
or not so this is the problem of record
linkage also known as data matching
entity resolution or merge
etc
so application of record link is many so
that hospital records uh a patient
showing in the age of five he has shared
some records and is gross and she's
records is going growing in different
locations different place so we have to
connect his lifelong records from
different sources different centers so
this is one of the application of record
linkage and another application is that
a person
she had she might have records in
different locations different systems
maybe one is a medical system one is uh
banking system or one is in another
social
service systems so we have to link this
record so there are many applications
of this record linkage
solutions problem
so challenge of health record link is in
developing countries like bangladesh
real health data available for record
linkages contains high amount of noise
as already i have shown
so data pre-processing is required for
better recording case that is missing
data imputation this one is there is
many attributes in the in the software
in the system but most of the time they
are always full they fill up the
important information so they can make
it quickly so they are amazing in the
missing data so we have to if we want to
process this
data we need to develop the missing data
imputation and how can we reduce the
noise so this is the challenge one of
the challenge another is unique entity
as i have already said unique entity
keys are not available in the most in
most cases so then i said that we have
cost identifier there is we can have to
use address databar center etc to make a
key for the uh the
patient
and thirdly health record linkage
applications use sensitive and protected
health data that is why i have already
said that it needs privacy preservation
that is we have to anonymize the data by
using hashing techniques
and use volume of data and frequent
updates in database is a big data era so
you see that in bangladesh say 12 000
sources of data and if the 12th of the
source and all data is integrated in on
one place every every day there will be
millions of records and and
if we have to make the clustering of
millions of records including the
previous billions of records so it is
you must have an incremental approach
for the
linkage
algorithm that is why you have developed
an incremental approach algorithm for
this
to make is feasible
so this is a example of how how we need
pre-processing here this different id in
uh same patient different system so this
is an example that is we have to handle
and same patient with different name so
this is another example and
these missing data some uh the data this
important data but it is missing
or sometimes some something is wrong
data this is gender and male is maybe
new numeric data binary true or false or
male and female is so these these things
are we have to handle so this is the
generalization of the problem of of this
record linkage so you see that there are
many healthcare service providers
hh sp one two is n number providers a
patient may go different hospitals now
we have to link all the records of the
patient
maintaining the privacy preservation
using um the non-identify
and identifiable attributes and define
generating a key so that the all same
records come together for a single
patient so this is the
generalization of the the problem of
record linkage the developing issue
efficient techniques for recording case
of noise health data with privacy
preservation
so here we have used
this is the base data set we can
we
have considered then we have the select
the features that which is for
determining or our applications our lab
analysis so based on this we have select
the features and based on the features
so this is the operational data set from
the operational data sets we have have
the reduced uh data set and that reduced
data set now we are we have to
pre-process the data
for missing data imputation so here
we have used that missing data in some
data we have injected firstly so that we
can get a
training and test data set and by this
we have generated a data set with
missing values and
this dataset we have used with some
algorithm for missing that imputation
and then we have
got an empty data set and we have the
initial data set and from this we have
compared we have the performance
evaluation so this we have done for
missing data imputation
and we have used formatting algorithm to
reduce uh
in the record linkage say foundation in
algorithm for name and ambiguous data so
that here you see that a name a person
name arif is
written here are if in
here and rf indifferently so
though names are different they are they
seem uh sim seems to be the same same
person same patient so we have used uh
formatting and encoding techniques by
financing we have reduced and the the
names into the phonetic code and
that phonetic code represents that this
is a one a single person in these
algorithms we have used for formatting
and coding
and that privacy preservation recording
is linkage of records without disclosing
identifying attribution and and and
individuals so this is in the names
linkage of blind data or private linkage
records so this so we have we have done
this in this
case
rl algorithm
so this is passion data set
here
in the data set there are three types of
data changeable attributes
unambiguous attributes and ambiguous
attributes
the changeable attributes is like weight
mobile number it may be change over time
but
that date of birth it will never change
and
the name address is ambiguous written in
differently different places so we have
divided the data into these three groups
and we have
uh avoided this changeable attributes
for our linkage of course and for
unambiguous attributes we have used the
generalization technique and for
ambiguous attributes we have the
formatting and encoding and after that
we have done the hashing techniques and
by hashing we have
after concatenation we have generated
the key for the
patient for linkage of the record
special patient records
and so this is
the algorithm called ks rl algorithm
case rl key will come in detail in the
in the later slides
so this is my proposed ppirl privacy
preserving incremental record linkage
framework
so input data set based data set we have
used data pre-pricing as per we have
already discussed filling missing data
removing unwanted values transforming
data or transformation after
transformation we have got the
privacy preservation of the data by
formatting encoding and generalization
and then for performance uh purpose we
have used the blocking technique so that
that all data should not be compared to
the full data so for incremental we have
used the blocking the attributes uh as
blocking key or or partition key so then
we have uh perform the clustering of the
data the clustering using agno media
hierarchical clustering and after
clustering we get
we have evaluation
we evaluated the
generation of the
keys for the
link is
measuring leakage quality and privacy
evaluation after evaluation in this way
so
so first base data set we have
done the clustering for the whole data
and now once the data is clustered and
then the initially so now the
the whole data will never be clustered
that will be we have an infinite
incremental algorithm where each
increment will come
and
this process will be done all for the
increment only and in the clustering of
the increments will be compared with the
existing clustering based on the
blocking so in this way we have
handled the performance issues of
the big data
so so far i have
discussed about our record linkage
so should i
expect some discussion on this record
linkage or i move for the full this full
session and then we can discuss what do
you think
okay i proceed and then we'll come
later in the discussion
so then we started on the developing of
the warehouse based on the record
linkage so these we have
done this researchers the privacy
preserving national clinical data
warehouse architectural analysis
so this is the problems in bangladesh in
health health the one of the scenario
that everything is missing
so how can we systematic uh bring into
the systems so that is very difficult to
work so
also the population is is 161 million
populations they have very high
populations and there
also is a high visit for every every
year the budget is increasing for health
so
uh the now the
about the health records i have already
mentioned some that when while we are
going to develop a health depository a
big data repository for health or health
data warehouse so we have already
discussed that inconsistency no record
linkage is therefore and no reusable no
interoperability and facing lack of
research data sets so i discussed only
record linkage problems previously but
when we go to implement a big data
repository in
connecting all the resources of the
country so really
many other problems arises so these are
some of the problems i can i
discuss that and another inadequate
disease analysis it is not there is no
scope of disease analysis no data
available in digital analysis currently
and risk computation forecasting no data
that can we can forecast some things
that what this that may happen on
decision making and data driven research
this all the things are absent in
because of the
data repository
and
as a result there's poor
healthcare services severe health crisis
you have found severe health crisis
during the pandemic situation the people
have to suffer a lot because of the data
because of the
the system so it creates the critical
situation and male distribution of
national and regional health coverages
so this is definitely because as there
is no central repository central
monitoring so there is a distribution of
resources distribution management of
resources there are so many other
problems for this
and
uncontrolled uncontrollable communicable
and non-community diseases because in
asian countries there's many times we
have the infection of diseases
communicable diseases on the spread it
becomes like an epidemic so how in the
patient may comes you you have no way no
tool to manage the epidemic in a in a
structured and and efficient way
so our solution is anonymous anonymized
clinical data hub
so here is the
problem domain we can say in national
research laboratory in 2013 medical
research institute in bangladesh like
birdham icdrp and like this there are
very big research uh institutes and
regional provisional specialized
laboratory there is total of uh
institution 200 2277
and medieval college is 112 and other
institutions 16
1672
and 605 government
hospitals in all together in bangladesh
and also
as per the bangladesh private clinic and
diagnosis almost as shown there are
eight thousand diagnosed centers of the
country uh djs approval so all together
there are more than twelve thousand data
sources that are generating data it is
huge
so now
they are
developing laboratory data that are
developing genomic data molecular data
so now our
approach is how can we integrate this
data to a central clinical research
another big data platform
and at the same time
is as our
uh
developing countries and also
the nature of tropical countries there
are many infectious diseases to handle
in that case we have to
integrate ambient data that is
environmental factors and
data and
and we want to integrate as well
behavior and lifestyle data so that we
can help in personalized medical care as
well
so ultimately the outcome will be that
reinforce the research and analysis
based on this
data and also policy and decision making
for the health services
so challenges we have solved until now
data privacy and security to ensure
private safety we have developed the key
base secured record link is algorithms
hipaa compliance and ethical clearance
from bmrc
and data integration from heterogeneous
sources with secure record linkages we
have
developed a repair-based data
integration model to integrate the data
from different sources
and data standardization data exchange
and interoperability operability which
we have been working now standardized
data dictionary based on snowbird city
lions icd 11 some other standards we are
going to implement
and developing a highly secure and
scalable clinical big data repository in
a flexible variable format so for this
we have developed this data warehouse a
multi-dimensional data model for this so
these these are
our work we have
done some work has been done in some
ways in under process so this is our
architecture for the national clinical
data warehouse
so here
are the sources source for every source
we have to implement a wrapper
and then the purpose of the rapper to
extract data
with the anonymity anonymous innovation
using other our recording algorithm
and some kinds of pre-processing will be
here but
mostly here for anonymization we can
implement the wrapper for a source and
that through the wrapper we can get an
api through an api you can get the data
to our
location so in this way we have designed
a number of wrappers for different
hospitals and those are running their
system
and through the wrapper we can get the
anonymous anonymized data in our system
and then
when we get the anonymize data then we
perform the data cleaning noise
reduction here and after data cleaning
and run noise reduction based on our
algorithms so we can get the clean data
and after that
this temporary heterogeneous data
storage this data will be stored where
transformation because for determining
knowledge discovery we need to transform
the data to normalize the data so that
we can use machine learning algorithms
and determine algorithms and at the same
time we need to standardization because
without standardization we this ansi dw
cannot be interoperability and and
international standard
so the standardization is done here and
then after that we upload the data
using a
uh start schema the data wire schema as
per the data schema we have designed the
data schema so that it supports
all the disease classes as per data
available in the source
so as we are taking all the source data
in the data warehouse so definitely it
will support
all the disease classes we have
considered that icd-11 this is last year
and from the nctw
it will we have developed algorithms to
develop different data marks
and these data marks each data mark for
handling one disease disease class
so one may be one data mark for diabetic
one data verb for i
say any inference say drain good disease
entertainment for coping in this way we
have designed the database and from each
data mart we can run the all up systems
all up uh
techniques to and the analysis dss
applications and all this also other
things and then we
can also
use data mining here from the nctw or
olap so this is our architecture for the
national clinical data warehouse
so source wrapper if we consider the
source for we have used the case rl
algorithm using the patient name first
name
last name
and gender data birth address we have
because this
covers all the
ambiguous attributes and then we
generate the patient identifier kpik
uh so therefore this is the for patient
safety and this is the ph national
algorithm so we have the patient name we
have as a signal part of the patient we
have the name of the we have taken an
omega's portion and then we have mass
and this is the value and then from this
we can we can have the hashing so at the
same gender date of birth address we
have used to generate this uh
patient key that is for leg record
linkage and we have found that the
accuracy of our algorithm for linkage
records is about
96.2 percent when we apply it in our
data set and dna identification is not
possible from the efficiency so that we
are we can
say that this system is privacy
preserving nobody can break the privacy
of a patient
and we have done the data modeling and
analysis that that is operational data
analysis you see that all the database
systems running in each and every
sources they are running their
operational database operation system so
all the attribution of the operation
system is not suitable for data mining
or knowledge discovery so we have
classified the attributes to have the
investigated three health information
systems uh after investigating health
information systems we have developed
that data analyzed that entity
relationships are almost the same
structure we have found and
77 percent left chest are identical and
interchangeable is among these three uh
sources we have found
and but the remaining person different
data grouped into three categories
one is health care information includes
health care profile location branch
contracts leviticus etc for health care
information because we need to analyze
the base on the healthcare sources
and we need to analyze of the patient
details for national analysis registered
outpatient and patient information
including name gender derived contact
address resistance etc
and
and medical records that is we have used
laboratory tests diagnosis notes inter
uh
interpretations of test comments so so
far as data is available we can
integrate to our warehouse
this is the multi-dimensional data model
where this is the factorable for test
results so here is the patient uh pik is
the the for patient is for patient
diversity pik there were time key health
care key then left key
test group key test key attribute key
then
reference range key so all these key
involves each and every key
is included for a particular analysis of
the based on that key so if we consider
that
if we consider the patient key so we can
develop the analysis on based on the
patient age
present gender ethnicity and then the
space of the
location of the patient of the opazilla
district division and demography all
these kind of analysis can be done on uh
based on the patient key and similarly
uh all kind of different tests so we can
use this
test item demo test key we can for this
different test week analysis if we want
to develop a data mart for
a particular disease we can use these
attributes the test group and test items
and test attributes based on these
three dimensions we can generate the
data marks for different diseases
disease classes
so and at the same time
for
time key in you see that
spreading disease on different places we
have to use the time key so which are
the time based analysis we can use for
time dimension and the resource
allocation research management for
resource management we can use the
healthier dimension for resource
management and this is the reference
range reference key is used for for
medical research that here is the
reference and here is the the value
actually below they can compare whether
that the this value is under the
reference value or over the reference
below they can
they can define the the result of the
what is they can group the that the
patient into different groups the
disease classes so here are lots of
research uh
opportunities to do on the both in
computer science research and also the
health research
and these are some hierarchy for
uh
grouping and analysis of
based on different groups we can perform
these are they are mainly used for
computationally
viable and making the things competition
easier so you can use this hierarchy
so we have some uh limited experimental
results so far because just recently we
have got the permission from the
government and from the bmrc clearance
so there is
before we got the clearance we could not
do so much
research and development on this so we
did some limited uh research
implemented a limit uh limited uh
nctw uh uploading limited amount of data
actually we uploaded uh from three
hospitals we uploaded 1.16 million
records uh to the uh to the warehouse
and there we found that after linkage
algorithm we found that there are 9445
uh distinct patients we have found from
this 1.16 million records and these are
the number of patients the participant
to the warehouse and number of tests we
can found that there is 1135
distinct tests on this on this data and
there are total number of tests we have
found there is 6256
attributes here
and we have implemented the three
data marks on these diabetes and this
hiv and then good database and for these
data marks we have some some results
say
for the dengue data mart so we have
found the forum from this three hospital
data there are these are the this curve
shows that the number of pes uh a
patient tested and this is the number of
patients infected so here is the
conclusion is that the june to september
june to september months are the most
critical time for dengue outbreak in the
demographic of bangladesh so this is
this is found
if we have the real data on the
real-time data will be uploading so
real time when the month of june we can
say that oh this is the
the position of django now spreading all
over the country and every day we can
tell
that before before getting the
information for many sources and
collecting data from the warehouse you
can say that oh this is is increasing so
now we take the decision and which part
of the country if we show that location
based analysis see that these are the
areas that lingua is spreading so now
check the measure for control and then
step steps to here so for for inter year
analysis you can say that every year
this this is a django prone area so that
government can take special measures to
stop the drink of in that area so this
is the analysis possible for
from the data warehouse and this is from
diabetic data diabetes data mart so in
the diabetes data mart we see that so
this is the normal those are tested they
are normal these are the number of
normal these three diabetics and this is
the diabetes so here the diabetes
developing age is uh 27 or
uh are older and more developed in 40 to
40 to 70 years yes you see that more
this is this is natural
it's similar to the data but it has come
from the date of the data warehouse
based on the analytics
and this is an another analysis from
subtrees and
other
ldl and hdl analysis
so this is another finding
so in this type of findings we can say
that uh diabetes patient operates t is
greater than 150 milligram per unit and
age 25 to 40 has picked
so this is the record linkage uh example
link link record so one
so this is the pik for this pik
all her
gender is female all her records are
linked
as per the different hospitals and
different systems different tests so
we have got this result for record
linkage
so up to now so we have uh
the we have presented our uh performance
of the national clinical data warehouse
so now this uh data warehouse we are
using for continuous research so
we are we have taken some
project to work on so this is one of the
project for standardization we have we
have got the grant from
uh
ministry of ict division to work on the
on this generalization project clinical
data standardization by developing
interoperability framework as i have
already mentioned the standard is very
essential for the performance of our
clinical data warehouse so we are in the
standardization process
we are
uh
we are
uh
that this domain we are
including domain experts and
international standards we are giving
the input from this domain expert and
standard
and this is the national clinic data
standards interoperability framework so
when this will be developed so it will
be used by different health care
services healthcare providers they must
develop their software based on these
clinical standards and will develop in
the publish it and clinical builder
platform we will use also as well and
this is
uh that must be an easy to
interface and resident coding system so
that so that this can be used easily so
this
standardization we are working on
so these are the standards we are going
to
incorporate in our standardization
process that is data intelligence uh
format omop at the end uh snowman city
lions and nhs reference in bangladesh
most of the health services and medical
records they use those nhs this british
standard
so you have to consider that as well and
we are considering icd-11
for cover of all our disease classes
and another
work in progress that we are
personalized secured pressure patient
record because when anonymized records
so there are
while we are getting uh
asking permission from the government
from director general health
then they asked the question what the
citizens will get from your data
warehouse
so then we thought that okay
what service we can provide to the
citizens then we
introduce a project that is blockchain
based patient record linkage system for
big data analytics so that the patient
can store his own data in his own way no
no privacy preservation because he can
access data he can store data and he can
retrieve data in his and he'll be the
owner of the data
so this framework we are just currently
just under the
test visa
to answer the question the how much we
can use blockchain for our
data privacy and
without anonymization how much we can
use the
data
to give the service to the patients
so without anonymization so that is why
we are doing research on this personal
uh decentralized blockchain
infrastructure so every patient with the
consent of the patient so the every
uh
health information service provider
so he can
put his data to the
blockchain or for his important data
that is he will be the owner of the of
the data
and
in this way the and
that is
unambiguous data there is
the data that is not
breaking the privacy pressure from his
own data can be stored from different
different hospital that he can link by
its as well and these data also can come
by anonymization to the lineal data
repositories so this part we have been
working on currently
and another this is also work in
progress integration of environmental
factor so we have a project with the
department of environment so to
integrate the environmental factor into
the warehouse to
measure the impact of environment factor
on our infectious disease spreading so
engineering climate data into clinical
data warehouse for infectious disease
from civilized images all these these
are the
they are working on this project they
have got the
fellowship for for this work
so the public health and anticipation is
that when where and how fast and how
widely an infectious disease will spread
and how great a state or region of the
population to take the measure of this
not only the clinical data is not
sufficient to answer this type of
questions so we have to consider the the
environment factor as well then latitude
and longitude along longitudinal
latitude and
seasonal and
inter-annual
association between climate and
infectious diseases and quantification
of the evidence-based uh vibrant
environmental factors so this is we have
to consider and forecasting infectious
diseases outbreak based on the
environmental factors so there is how
you have considered these are these
factors the temperature and
temperature rainfall and humidity
and
also there are wind speed and cloud
amount and sunshine so these are not
available currently in the in the
environmental factors so these
temperature rainfall and humidity so we
are using this uh data to in
integrate to our
nctw so
now if we consider that there are 12 000
uh
data sources
and
and there are 4 495 upon so
administrative division is 495
all over the country but 12 000 is the
individual
so here is
in the
bmd bangladesh meteorological department
or the station they have only
35 station they are collecting this oil
data
so now if we are to integrate this
weather environment factor into the data
warehouse so
i need data for
495
locations
to integrate
as per the location at the opposite
level
and if i want to
integrate all the data to 12 000 sources
in that case i have to make it for 12
000 sources yeah based on their location
analysis so this
i have do we are doing as a
data interpolation method we are using
there is here a sample point these
points these points these are
known and this point is unknown so we
are developing the interpolation
algorithm so that we can get this data
develop this data by interpolation
so
the data intervals from this 35 stations
to 495 points and then we ultimately
need to interpolate to 12 000 points so
these we are we are working on it
and that there are also
to compare our interpolation method
their data from a satellite image data
they're from the image they have also
the
some data generating for this so we can
compare with this and then
thirdly we can integrate this
interpolated data to the
data warehouse for our big data analysis
now the future work and conclusions so
future work
you see that currently
we have integrated only the pathological
data because pathological data is easy
to integrate too easy to get it so we
need to integrate the other
data the radiology data generated
molecular socioeconomic factors
behavioral all these data so
if we have the full present we have to
extend in this way so that we can uh
include other data as well inshallah in
their
warehouse
and then
uh currently that is we have developed
a
data mart for diabetes dengue and hiv
data mars
so but we need to create data marks for
other acid relevant disease classes so
this is a
huge work to
develop and determine and also therefore
data and diabetic data mart there we
need to more analysis and algorithms to
transform the sctw data into the data
merge
so that the data mark is
there is 100 percent accurate or
the near 100 percent accuracy in there
so here it is
we have we need to involvement of the
physician that is medical health science
research and also computer science
research both needs to integrate it here
for depending the data marks from the
nctw different disease data mart
and also then we can
use the
different analysis from from from the
data mart
so digicenter knowledge based
development for predicting health risk
and corresponding wellness plans and
clinical reference distribution this is
one of another there is no clinical
reference we use the reference from the
uh who that is developed for uk or usa
so we use the same reference maybe it is
not either is true or false there is
some deviation we cannot we can we do
not know so we can find this division
and we can find our own reference
in bangladesh
and we can use for ole for health policy
support
and
generation of research dataset
ultimately we can develop a lots of
research dataset for both medical
research and computer science research
so this is our
vision to
go over the nct wo for that there is
under 60 million people will join to the
nctw so that they can have the
personalized benefit from the nctw and
12 000 health data sources that can be
kind of integrated to the nctw and
by the administration director general
health services that government other
research institutes and here uh
all the research institutional health
research they will be
connected and the computers has
researched lots of opportunities for
computer science research they can be
connected and it will be based on the
university center i'll be controlling it
yes
so this is
all together about the health and only a
few
minutes just i'll talk about my
e-learning projects
so i have my research in two direction
one is health and the data or big data
analytics and another in learning both i
have been doing for a couple of years
together so i have developed a
number of e-learning systems for that
are using for better learning in the
pandemic situation and also not
non-pending situation as well for in the
blended learning environment here is the
learning health data analytics in
virtual internet system i've developed
this available international
free internship.org
you can go there and see the system and
the system here what we have done that
universities interns health service
providers and researchers you can join
together to learn
the
different techniques of health services
for data analytics for
data
systems this is my system architecture
where the virtual industry environment
has been created using the data sets so
here we have used all health data health
related data white house data and health
other health data so that that their
system can be used by the
the
interns or learners and
by the guidance of the industrial
supervision industry mentorship
so this is the four components what is
admin and industry and mentor and intern
these four components are
included in this in a system so that
they can learn together and
because there are problems the real
system working in the real system it is
not possible for
various reasons
those who are on to learn the real
system they do not have the access to
the real system because of the privacy
concern so we have just virtual
environment so that everybody can learn
and work on like a real system
so these learn
health data analytics so
the structure of clinical laboratory
environmental sensors
they can learn data pre-processing noise
reduction missing value implication
normalization standardization they will
learn external transformation loading
and multi-dimensional data modeling and
then on all up and aggregation
correlation data mining everything based
on the health data so i have included in
this
module
and these are the working schedule of
the of this module or what i use
actually i used in the last
round i have been say about 20 interns
to learn the health data analytics
so their feedback is really impressive
so that one of the industry in
bangladesh they have taken my system to
popularize is to use in the real system
to teach the interns of cse graduates to
avoid the data analysis of health and
analytics
so this is the
methods one is learning that for
technology learning i have used some
synthesis uh data
for technology learning for data
analytics so they set the local
environment to their machines and they
work on this scenario data and they
start they upload the data to the data
or has format and they run the all of
queries and the visualization and
using these tools so they learn all this
data on analytics part here
using a
synthetic data set and then i have
used actually the real real update
health data analytics i have given this
schema to the
to the interns that you populate this we
have the raw data you populate this uh
warehouse schema so that you can get the
analytics you can learn the analytics
from this so this way they learn the
health data analytics in the
summary of the virtual learning of the
health data analytics teaching learning
using synthetic data database technology
programming environmental languages and
warehouse concept and technology they
learn using the synthetic data and then
they apply their knowledge to real-life
data with the power data and
anonymization instructional
pre-processing loading and headlight
analytics
so now all over the i have identified
that there may be a possible
collaboration with hsu uh that is
we can work together about the
standardization and interoperability
framework how can our system can be
interoperable so we can work together
knowledge transfer through training and
research so it can be a
method of collaboration possible
technology and data sharing as per the
government governing rules so we are
generating research data
so maybe there is opportunity for
data sharing as per the governing rules
you can uh do it and photographically
exchange program in different ways uh we
can have the further collaboration in
uh this uh with this and national
cleaning data warehouse and health
research
so
this is the outcome of the academy
industry research collaboration here's
my yesterday lab you become is um you
become love levi's marketing university
and my isoft is in industry and ubtx is
a us-based industry and institute of
information combination technology but
they also join with me and
uh spell thanks to bangladesh medical
research council for their ethical
clearance so this is my
uh presentation altogether
thanks a lot for patience hearing of my
talk thank you very much any question
you can find
us at esri lab and this is my
location you can see
any questions here from anyone
i graduated from
95 right so
i i think i know this is
extraordinary like you know what i have
seen here that you know is uh
something people right now such a big
system right at the national level i
think bangladesh can be done and as he
talked about more on the logistic side i
do what his request is
you know this is enormous like you know
on the escape so i have a few questions
right now so that i don't
take all the time so um when you
it did all these when you started all
this right you know how you were
thinking scaling this right you know
right now then you've got the clearance
like you know what is that the biggest
framework right now is it like an open
source or is it appropriately a database
later that will be
storing all these data and as the the
data is being accumulated over the the
months days right and how how this
information will be stored or that
operating there's some data loss or
something i can say so uh and
okay thanks a lot for the question this
is a very important question
so for this uh what we are thinking that
uh now we are developing the model and
bullet authority authority has granted
us a resource
for testing the models during the model
we are using the data center for for
this purpose
and they have given several terabytes of
storage
and i think uh
64gb ram and virtual
environment to
test the warehouse
and we'll do the research part from all
kinds of systems developing the systems
integrating systems testing the wrappers
into even the reports
testing the algorithm for record linkage
and when it will be perfect and it it
actually it is
difficult for the university to host the
whole thing
so maybe you will pro profess we are it
is under process a discussion that we
will sign an mou with the government
so that government either the government
can uh establish a data center
especially for this purpose that do it
and it will be owned by government and
poet so that way to do the research part
and the
government will use this for decision
making and other purpose in this way we
are finally doing this and we will send
the proposal to the government
final implementation as long as final
implementation will do only the research
part
okay well i think we're about out of
time so um thank you again for
coming and it sounds like this is
potentially the beginning of a
collaboration uh between ohsu and bowit
and we'll we'll see where that goes and
i i hope that works out well so thanks
again
thank you okay
thanks
i'm gonna go to my next
guest everything
study various aspects of patient safety
provider behaviors
team provides the
so do you work with the navigators
so our team provides a workflow specific
like a speciality specific treatment
so when doctors would join
they get a basic uh heaviness field
which are that we do
they get the basic training but then we
then go in after about four weeks we go
in with each speciality is a different
work
so the first one is that just keep
showing that the basic functionality and
how we're going to navigate i'd like to
know that sometimes so yeah we see the
data on the from the back end
right i'm not facing the positive side
of the data
people from here like you won't imagine
that now how difficult it is even to
convince they're getting a small amount
of things right and just logistics well
then
so again if they have the similar
problem you know it's
so many providers
and nobody can you know there's so much
information coming in everybody's using
uh electronic health records and so they
are coming in from everywhere but you
know like you said we built our systems
to talk to each other to get everything
in and again
if you wanted to do it or the privacy
that you have
then application you cannot do this
those are important issues but the
policies these can be
booked or automated in minneapolis yeah
but we still have to have those
governments because they don't
necessarily
need to be there right you know but you
know all the logistics and the policies
that you know not having access to doing
anything rather than because i know this
is the policy right today i cannot share
any any information right
if you do the university like you know
anyone says
what
talked about like it
feel free to email me
we're doing resident training over the
next couple of weeks yeah we're starting
the training tonight
yeah i was alright by the jeff first and
then excited about that definitely thank
you it was nice meeting you guys
oh